[Music]
good morning it is tummy time it's belly
time or tummy time
tummy time
how are we doing today
luka
say joe's son joe's son me and tiff have
been trying to teach luca i i guess for
ourselves too to try to be as trilingual
in this house as possible trying to say
jose and buenos dias that's how tiff
says it good morning good morning i'm
like buenos dias
good morning not a first date good
morning buenos dias joe's son
i don't know if i'm saying it right with
the joe said joseph here give him a baby
i gotta go mama's gotta go
miss you so much where are you going
today i'm gonna go shoot big mood and
daddy's not coming today i know it's my
first time not going to big mood a long
time yeah well actually ever yeah since
i started
he's like no mommy don't leave
how do you leave a face like that oh how
do you do it you're a monster in life
wow i'm just like you've done it before
you actually shot big mood without me
i'm already since i'm a monster since
he's been born i was left home all alone
and he was a lot younger too true at
least now you've got into a group of
things daddy's gonna do fine with you
huh true there's a ton of frozen i hope
so
i hope so there's a lot of diapers you
should probably put the new liner on oh
yes beforehand
[Music]
set
[Music]
your baby boy
and your brother's not home
he's with his daddy on the weekend
what do you want to go do today same
thing we do every night try to take over
the world
nerf all right i love you
bye love you too
here you go
[Music]
oh we will i have a feeling i'll forget
something
um
[Laughter]
then we have nikki blades in the house
so we're going to be shooting just the
three of us just the three of us
well four technically because pat's here
as you already know casey's home with
luca and i miss him so much
but let's uh let's shoot hi pat hi have
you been good so he's filling in for
casey so thank you so much because
thanks for
thanks to you coming here and filling up
for casey casey you could be at home
with her newborn oh yeah no problem so
thank you
but yeah
we gotta get started ladies oh and then
look
ladies help me put on these uh press-on
nails because i have a freaking claws
right now i haven't seen tiff in forever
i know since i was pregnant since she
was pregnant no more baby here so crazy
do you have your chunk already oh dude i
bought like 16 different pairs tested it
out every day
see the trajectory you see which one is
the hardest like i gotta dance with
science we're good what are we throwing
chocolate
she always says that um she's gonna be
throwing chocolates at my my child yeah
the moment he comes out like that the
chocolate that's flying in wow what are
we teaching them how to bob and weave
all right okay okay we got a boxer on
our hands no she's being a good dia
cause that's that's what you gotta do
you gotta teach the kids to have respect
for their others with the chocolate got
it
kids don't know this but i was actually
i knew where they were giving birth so i
stood outside the operating room for the
birth room with my chocolate but they
didn't let me in so it's cool
all right so getting anything done with
luca and no help is a lot harder than i
thought it was going to be kitchen is a
bit of a mess just because i've been
cooking the last couple of days and uh
been trying to get it cleaned but every
time i put him down he wakes up from his
nap and then before you know it i gotta
feed him again and change his diaper so
this is proven to be much more difficult
i have no idea how tiff did it with
isaac as a single mother and i don't
understand how any single parent could
get anything done other than tend to
their child so hats off to single
parents i am living the next six hours
of my life as a single parent
we'll see how it goes all right we just
wrapped the first episode
running a little bit behind and these
press-on nails that i put on they're so
sharp i keep scratching myself but i
miss lucas so much and my boobs miss
them too cause they are completely full
and now i'm gonna take a pumpkin break
in between these episodes so
i brought my breast pump i'm gonna use
gina's room to pump yeah i miss my boys
i wish i knew what they were doing i
want to kiss luca right not so bad
how's that
what do we do you want this how's this
okay so luca has had trouble sleeping
uh he doesn't like sleeping anywhere
other than in your arms i'm actually
able to sue them right now only because
he's in the bouncer is this the bouncer
or jumper or rocker or glider slider i
think it's a bounce bouncer because it's
bouncing yes it's bouncing so anyways
luca has to have some sort of like
motion
for him to be content i guess at the
moment at this stage in his life and so
when it comes to putting him down for
his naps and sleeping at night he only
sleeps when he's being rocked the trick
about that is he only stays sleeping if
you're rocking him yeah so i don't know
if i'm gonna be able to get to anything
i originally had planned to do so it's
just literally me and luca today
attached to the hip is that right luca
you're gonna be attached to the hip
today but uh i already did the
essentials i uh changed his diaper once
since tiff left and i've already fed him
once since tiff left he did poop on me
earlier today like before tiff left but
other than that pretty smooth sailing i
would say are you having a good time
yeah we've been uh
trying to integrate our languages with
luca so i've been talking to him in
cantonese like
hey and honestly i think me trying to
teach luca some cantonese
in the long run is actually going to
help me with my cantonese because i've
forgotten so much that it's going to
force me to relearn a lot of stuff and
also just saying it out to him so the
thing about cantonese it's all about
tones right and if i don't practice my
cantonese i lose the muscle memory on
how to pronounce certain things because
of the tones it's like one little muscle
movement of your mouth off then you're
saying a completely different word like
just yesterday we went to go eat um some
hong kong food and i think um i was
teaching tif how to say cold water so
is cold
but we also asked for sugar so tong dong
tong it's it's like essentially the same
thing you know in english you could say
a certain word with a different accent
multiple ways but it means the same
thing but in chinese it's not so much
it's like a completely different word
and so yeah i'm practicing my tones and
and uh it's gonna ultimately help me too
i guess the most unfortunate thing for
you is that if i have an accent that
means you're gonna have an accent so
welcome to accent and cantonese okay so
i'm pumping right now see yeah you can't
see nothing but i'm pumping and gina and
nikki they were like wait a second
i've never had breast milk before and
neither has gina so gina is looking at
me like are we about to do this and i'm
like are we about to do this she's like
i think we're about to do this and i'm
like i think so too and i don't know if
i'm lactating now but i think that i'm
black like these things just like i
think i'm lactating just the thought of
tasting her lactation so how do you
properly consume breast milk do we chill
it do we put it on the wrong side
i'm like go get some shot glasses i'll
give you some of my breast milk do i put
it in do i put it in a in my coffee how
do i can i put it on my face
actually yeah it's really good
moisturizer so do i gotta pay i'll give
you a shot for free shots are like
twenty dollars a shot these days like
you know inflation it's like gas prices
well look how much one is more exciting
than the other because i fed him out of
this one before leaving come on this one
this one looks
can i get the lift can i get left titty
mouth please excuse me hi can i get a
left titty mouth um
can i get it off the rocks
do we top it can i turn it into whipped
cream oh there's something crazy
they're so excited it's so funny but i'm
right here sitting looking at pictures
of luca to get my uh oxytocin going to
release some more milk but i forgot my
breast milk bags i don't know how many
more times i had to pump throughout this
day i'm probably gonna have to end up
dumping some or then maybe they could
just drink it all
i'm gonna freeze it
it's gonna be lotion later
i don't think that's how it works you
can do a milk bath bathe me in your
breath
so if you've ever seen the show
spartacus there's always the scenes
where the queen or whoever the important
lady is in a bath and there are people
bathing her that is a dream of mine to
be bathed in milk
and it's just extra it fits your breasts
to smell it is really expensive it's
actually really nutri nutritious you'll
probably drink it too it's actually
really sweet you'll see you'll see right
now what'd you eat today did you eat
garlic because i don't mind i don't like
garlic
i don't think it'll even taste like
garlic
so i have this much you guys are
stealing from my son look you're robbers
tim was pumping and then she was pumped
in my room and i looked at her like hey
yo
so what you gonna do with that
i've always wanted to try and then nicki
looked at me she's like
i was looking at you
like yeah we gotta do this like once the
next time i have a pregnant lady pump
milk in my room that i can try some
breast milk i've always wanted to try
i'm doing it
it is you guys are about to have my milk
tin of milk
how much of each no
like
audrey like a nice little
gulp okay okay okay you know okay we're
about to try human breast milk for the
first time from this right here from
that human
so i have a thing we have to come up
somebody has to say cheers okay uh to
our husbands or to our boyfriends
um and may they never meet each other
cheers
that's [ __ ] sweet
[Music]
it's sweet
it's sweet it's yeah right oh my god
there's like this milky aftertaste but
it's not
like strong it's super sweet like it i
want some more right here i got more you
want more what
this is crazy here
all of it all right that's two ounces of
milk that luca doesn't get but you guys
all right luca this is for you
i'm stealing a baby's life source right
now i love this
i compare it to almond milk no it's
better than almond milk that's good
that's interesting oat milk tastes like
dust this don't taste dusty
milky that's like it's milky that's
amazing we've all been bonded you guys
yeah
you have you have ingested my milk
i've always wanted you in me yeah right
that's the only way i'll get it i've
never ingested a woman's fluids before
there you go
[Applause]
no more no more no more
we are now like bonded for life yeah all
right i've had this fluids inside me yep
there is no ending a friendship like
this ever ever this is amazing wow
what is going on you made that out of
your boobies yeah so you mean one day
i'm gonna be able to do the same thing
yeah i wonder if i'm gonna taste like
pineapple juice you know what's crazy i
think you guys get to taste something
different than i taste cause like you
know you can't like smell your own bo or
like your own right when i tasted my own
milk it tasted like a like sweet nothing
it it almost has like a vanilla
i couldn't taste to it kind of give you
a flavor it's just sweet it just feels
creepy it tasted creamy and sweet i want
to put this in my coffee now i got my
coffee let's pour some in there i'll
tell you guys
if she got extra i want her to bathe me
yeah oh i bet that'd be so good for your
skin yeah
it really is actually i have some breast
milk that kind of went bad because i
didn't put in the freezer fast enough
can i put it on my skin so i have like
don't don't do not feed milk frozen
right all right we're about to film the
last episode now because nikki has to go
catch her flight back to the bay we've
been doing pretty good i think we've
been doing pretty great it's been a
pretty good day but i have been
internally miserable because i miss luca
so much this is the longest time i've
ever been away from him like i'm ready
to run home as soon as we wrap up it's
like i'm bolting home i can't wait to
see him what he's been up to ah but
casey's been sending me pictures
[Music]
[Music]
we're all wrapped yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
all right guys we finally completed our
four episode day can't believe we did it
but we did it
and now i get to go home and see lufka i
miss my baby look a baby look a baby
look who's home
[Music]
mama's home
mama's home
i missed you so much my boy how was it
your first full
day away from baby it was horrible oh
robot just kidding no i missed them so
much but the day went by pretty fast
yeah oh man i get home and now
it gets things all over i know behind my
baby it's a badge of honor where we're
proud i know hi
i missed you my boy mama missed you so
much yeah uh had the least productive
day ever so i am super glad you're home
now you know why it's hard for me to do
anything and i'm like how did you ever
do it as a single parent before i know
you know having luca makes me question
everything with isaac in the beginning
when isaac was his age we were living
with his dad so i didn't have to worry
about
working so i was just focused on isaac
but when he was three months old is when
i started working and then it took him a
babysitter and then from then on i
started going to school who watched him
when i went to school probably his
grandma i really can't remember this is
a long time ago like the longer time
goes and the more i'm dealing with luca
now like i'm forgetting a lot of like
how i handled isaac when he was little
it really feels like i'm a first-time
mom all over again bless you
cutie i know people are probably
wondering like where's isaac and where
how come he's not involved oh yeah with
luca well let me tell you why he's not
involved with this blog yeah a lot of
you guys been wondering yeah so isaac he
doesn't want to be in the vlogs so we're
not going to force him to be in these
videos if he doesn't want to be it's
just whenever he wants to be then that's
when he'll get to be in it but if you
don't see isaac it doesn't mean that
he's not included in anything it just
means he's deciding to not be in front
of the camera yeah that's it he's
entering his teen years and his team
vibes and so he's
you know got his own thing going on he's
got his friends got his respect
so obviously we're not going to be
forcing a camera on his face if he
doesn't want to but just so you know
he's home like he's here not today
because today he was his dad but all
this time for like the whole first month
that luca was born he didn't go to his
dad's that whole week like that whole
month for the weekend so he's been home
and he's been a good big brother we're
just not gonna stuff a camera in his
face and he doesn't want it that's why
like with even with luca now you're not
seeing us vlog like a whole ton because
we want to be mindful of like hey wait
he wants a shirt too so we're just
giving tiny little snippets
little snippets we're not showing
every minute of every day he's looking
away he's like not right now
no cameras please
[Music]
you